Hellboy is coming to injustice to as
part of the game's second character pack
on November 21st but thanks to a live
stream from NetherRealm you can see him
in action right now and if you want to
check out some of the other fighters on
injustice twos roster we've got plenty
of other character breakdowns for you to
watch too basically two options here
punch you in the face or punch you and
pop you in the head
that's this guy's normal attacks his
combos are very simple very
straightforward
he's just bashing but would you like an
order of punch with a side of more
punching mm-hmm there's two main normals
that I wanted to show okay's 43 has
really great range and it's a bid and it
pops up and it's seen so this is like
his core like nutrigain food and you can
go into a special move to start a combo
which I'll show later the second one is
actually a kick it's a high hoof high
huh and it's a slam down and again
tremendous range like I can actually be
at the start of the stage and babu's are
relatively fast for such middle legs
they have symmetry yes and then lastly
his back one is a combo starter a low he
does not have a really fast overhead
Hellboy's not meant to be like a
overhead low mix-up character he's just
a brawler up close he's just swinging
his so he thought he's all about the mix
this is just not there is one special
moves about the mix but up close this is
not a finesse character you're not doing
cancels you're not going into stances if
you want a Hellboy and you just want to
take a big rock head and punch someone
in the jaw that's someone like I mean
his back 3 is just high so yeah ok white
boys probably like really enjoy this but
that's kind of yeah if you want a
character that's like alright here's my
5 like pop you on the head moves that
you go so let's go with this throat he
actually loses the legendary King Arthur
sword Excalibur straight from Merlin
look at
only uses it for a very special occasion
from the stone yeah awesome all right so
let's go over a special news
somebody asked on the street chat
command grabs command grabs tell me more
well he's got this one it is a true
command grab you cannot block it but you
can't duck it it is a hot
however the nice thing is it acts as a
combo extender if you Peter Byrne oh
you're not really bad he's old and
washed up there it is you wouldn't the
down to why not all right so that's
gonna be one of those main combo
extenders and it's a pretty decent mix
up tool he also has an anti Arab where
he slams them down and if you meet upper
this it's also a combo extenders so that
will lead to a lot of us be a fee stuff
like those do the anti-air grab and then
you get a back three so a lot of this
stuff does have when you meter burnin it
is to extend the comment exactly
normally without leader he's not really
like a combo character he's not the role
yeah he just kind of punches you in the
face a bunch and then you gotta meet her
burn
alright what else is the ast he also has
some slight zoning with his devil's
revolver this is not meant to be like a
Deadshot wrist shot or a doctor fate pew
pew
but it's the projectile they can get the
job done and you can actually hold it
and then dash out of it he also has an
anti-air one and the meter brutal on
blows you away
it also has shot at star sound team an
amazing sound effect when a meter
burning secondly he has a devils
shoulder which is very reminiscent of
doomsday doomsday players they're really
gonna actually like doozy players are
gonna like this walk through what this
character for many reasons
if you meter burn it he slams you down
and on block you can actually do this
and you can change the timing to do it
early or late and it's actually
advantageous on block so you can see you
can do it and then he is plus and he's
not right next to you it's not like he
gets like oh my god he gets a block
infinite now but he stays safe he saves
plus and then he can kind of go into his
stuff
you could do that and then string four
to three and kind of check them and they
try to back - or whatever command grab
out you could do a command grab you
could do a jump attack gotcha
then he has a really unique move he has
this leap attack and he could do a
closed version a far version they all
look the same
there you go far version now this is
what's interesting this is one who I was
talking about his mix so you have a
relatively straightforward power
character and then you throw this in and
to me he kind of plays like a mix
between cheetah and Doomsday's so here's
what you can do you'll notice this is
the low one it hits ya and if you meet
her burn it so there's a lot you can do
with this you can actually air dash out
of it here - back - out of it so let's
say that you think they're gonna try to
anti-air and then you can go into this
move can you do normal attacks out of it
you can tell me more Steve for example
you can go straight into attack and now
overheads are jump attacks are overhead
which means if they sit there and block
you're gonna do that if you think
they're gonna try to duck you can go
into a jump attack you can also go pass
them and you can also just land cancel
it and do nothing at all
sure so to me his mix up game is gonna
be a lot about this leap doing the leap
by itself doing the leap over them then
crossing them up all kind of weird
shenanigans you can I'm gonna close the
space with Hellboy exactly because this
walk speed is not the best but his - is
really really fast but it doesn't like
go super super far so to me his mobility
is all going to be about this leap of
his walk isn't very fast but it menacing
it looks absolutely awesome look at your
looking down at it yeah baby's gonna
look down on everybody so one thing
people probably don't expect when we
showed him in the
he controls the air better than you
might expect yeah he also has an air -
using his demon powers he could just air
- periods so on the ground he's like
this really simple straightforward tank
like powerhouse puts his character and
then in the air he's going crazy so I
think like 50 percent of your games
gonna be like this methodical spacing
with four - and going into block
pressure but then 50 percent of your
minds gonna be uh going crazy just doing
leaps and diving over people and he'll
appeal to maniac players so next time
you speak about a levee notice that like
this beam - okay so let's talk about his
character power his character power is
he uses a bunch of charms and artifacts
and they give him buffs it's very
similar - wonderful
however unlike Wonder Woman you can
choose which buff you use now unlike
Wonder Woman they have a long cooldown
period so she could use her as
constantly in their random he has to
choose but he's gonna have to be smart
so he has four different buffs he can
use one of them increases the damage he
does and you can see he uses the
artifact and he gets his double orange
and this increases the damage he does
he's got the little crown on there
another one decreases the damage and he
takes a third one is actually a
resurrect when he has the Bell active if
he is killed in the second round he will
actually come back to life but only when
that is active as you look it moves
pretty fast
yes yeah it goes down fast yeah yeah and
then lastly he has armor so
you activate it and then he actually has
armor that you can just walk through
attacks take everything and you saw that
in the trailer when cyborg was trying to
zone him out and he actually was able to
just walk through it now this has a
pretty lengthy cooldown and he can only
absorb I think it's six hits before it
breaks sure buddy is very very good and
I think there you know again doomsday
players are gonna be feel at home here
well I feel taking damage yes you still
taking damage and he will go and do
somewhat of a hit reaction but it is not
a normal hit reaction and he is fully
armored everything like the super
very good awesome you know before the
before the batch is like I'm gonna put
that down in hell just in case this goes
crazy
so recently on Twitter we had that image
of Hellboy in gear for Halloween yeah
and a lot of people wanted to see his
gear because it was a really cool
preview sure I have some let's go let's
see it Steve
a lot of people actually didn't believe
that they were an actual costume his
gear is wild I like it oh he's got a lot
of guys he stuff
so in this loadout I gave him a guard
move where instead of his shoulder he
gets this move where he then can walk
and he will absorb projectiles and if
your meter Burnet you take virtually no
damage at all so if you're playing a
match where you're really getting sewn
into out and even the shoulder and the
Liebherr not good enough and they
control the air you got the gun I also
gave him a low grant where he Sue's them
up and they'll actually do damage she's
actually hitting them with a mystical
nail and if you meter burn it get a
combo so that's another combo extender
and it's a low grab so one more load out
of those Steve hey you got about the
buffet we didn't even talk about his
beautiful flame pants man and the five
man's room and this one is my more he's
embracing his demonic side he's no
longer trying to dress like a human he's
comfortable with his horns he doesn't
have his jacket on he's pure demon
Hellboy still smoking oh yeah I mean he
still has his vices it's hard to quit
here we go so here I gave him the tears
he throws down angel tears on the ground
that actually go fullscreen and travel
and if you meet her burn it it acts as
an awesome combo at center this tree
comes up
and then you can combo into it you draw
a lower base these are yeah all the
artifacts everything uses is all lower
base it's super cool and I have one more
bonus loaded notice okay
you're so good USD
yeah I really like this code Dean huh I
also I like I like the fist and I also
really appreciate the horseshoe on his
belt on his fist yeah we moved the gold
terminator
yes well yeah so in this loadout I gave
him two abilities that enhance his
zoning this one gives him an ear shot a
downward angle ear shot and then his
meter bring guns turned into triple guns
that works for all anti are beautiful
straight want to be triple and then if
you have this equipped to be true so if
you're a zoning player you really want
to zone but you want to play hello boy
there you go
I love it so that's how boy this is so
cool so cool
so like we said Hellboy will be
available